good evening I'm Pauline frederick of
NPR moderator of the second of the
historic debates of the 1976 campaign
between Gerald r Ford of Michigan
Republican candidate for president and
Jimmy Carter of Georgia Democratic
candidate for president Thank You
President Ford and Thank You governor
Carter for being with us tonight
this debate takes place before an
audience in the Palace of Fine Arts
Theater in San Francisco an estimated
100 million Americans are watching on
television as well
San Francisco was the site of the
signing of the United Nations Charter
thirty-one years ago thus it is an
appropriate place to hold this debate
the subject of which is foreign and
defense issues the questioners tonight
are max Frankel associate editor of the
New York Times Henry L Truitt diplomatic
correspondent of the Baltimore Sun and
Richard valeriani diplomatic
correspondent of NBC News the ground
rules tonight are basically the same as
they were for the first debate two weeks
ago the questions will be alternated
between candidates by the toss of a coin
governor Carter will take the first
question each question sequence will be
as follows the question will be asked
and the candidate will have up to three
minutes to answer his opponent will have
up to two minutes to respond and prior
to the response the questioner may ask a
follow-up question to clarify the
candidates answer when necessary
with up to two minutes to reply each
candidate will have three minutes for a
closing statement at the end President
Ford and governor Carter do not have
notes or prepared remarks with them this
evening but they may take notes during
the debate and refer to them mr.
Fraenkel you have the first question
for governor Carter
governor since the Democrats last ran
our foreign policy including many of the
men who are advising you country has
been relieved of the Vietnam agony in
the military draft we've started arms
control negotiations with the Russians
we've opened relations with China we've
arranged the disengagement in the Middle
East we've regained influence with the
Arabs without deserting Israel now maybe
we've even begun a process of peaceful
change in Africa
now you've objected in this campaign to
the style with which much of this was
done and you've mentioned some other
things that that you think ought to have
been done but do you really have a
quarrel with this Republican record
would you not have done any of those
things well I think this Republican
administration has been almost all style
and spectacular and not substance we've
got a chance tonight to talk about first
of all leadership the character of our
country and a vision of the future and
every one of these instances the Ford
administration has failed and I hope
tonight that I am mr. Ford will have a
chance to discuss a reason for those
failures our country is not strong
anymore we're not respected anymore we
can only be strong overseas if we're
strong at home and when I become
president we're not only be strong in
those areas but also in defense a
defense capabilities second to none
we've lost in our foreign policy the
character of American people we've
ignored or excluded the American people
into Congress from participation in the
shaping of a foreign policy it's been
one of secrecy and exclusion in addition
to that we've had a chance to become now
contrary to our long-standing beliefs
and principles the arms merchants of the
whole world we've tried to bind success
from our enemies and at the same time
we've excluded from the process the
normal friendship of our allies in
addition to that we've become fearful to
compete with the Soviet Union on equal
pay
we talked about daytime the Soviet Union
knows what they want in daytime and
they've been getting it we have not
known what we've wanted and we've been
out traded in almost every instance the
other part I want to make this about our
defense we've got to be a nation blessed
with a defense capability that's
efficient tough capable well organized
nearly focused fighting capability the
ability to fight if necessary is the
best way to avoid the chance fall or the
requirement to fight and the last point
I want to make is this mr. Ford mr.
Kissinger have continued on with the
policies and failures of Richard Nixon
even the Republican platform has
criticized the lack of leadership in mr.
Ford and they've criticized the foreign
policy of this administration this is
one instance where I agree with with a
Republican platform they might say this
in closing and that is that as far as
foreign policy goes mr. Kissinger has
been the president of his country mr.
Ford has shown an absence of leadership
and an absence of a grasp of what this
country is and what it ought to be
that's got to be changed and that is one
of the major issues in this campaign of
1976 President Ford would you'd like to
respond governor Carter again is talking
in broad generalities let me take just
one question that he raises the military
strength and capability of the United
States governor Carter in November of
1975 indicated that he wanted to cut the
defense budget by 15 billion dollars a
few months later he said he wanted to
cut the defense budget by eight or nine
billion dollars and more recently he
talks about cutting the defense budget
by five to seven billion dollars there
is no way you can be strong militarily
and have those kind of reductions in our
military appropriations now let me just
tell you a little story
about late October of 1975 I asked the
then secretary of defense mr.
Schlesinger to tell me what had to be
done if we were going to reduce the
defense budget by three to five billion
dollars a few days later mr. Schlesinger
came back and said if we cut the defense
budget by three to five billion dollars
we will have to cut military personnel
by 250,000 civilian personnel by a
hundred thousand jobs in America by a
hundred thousand we would have to
stretch out our aircraft procurement we
would have to reduce our naval
construction program we would have to
reduce the research and development for
the army the Navy the Air Force and
Marines by eight percent we would have
to close 20 military bases in the United
States immediately that's the kind of a
defense program that mr. Carter wants
let me tell you this straight from the
shoulder you don't negotiate with mr.
Brezhnev from weakness and the kind of a
defense program that mr. Carter wants
will mean a weaker defense in a poor
negotiating position mr. Truitt a
question for President Ford mr.
president my question really is the
other side of the coin from mr.
Frankel's for a generation the United
States has had a foreign policy based on
containment of communism yet we have
lost the first war in Vietnam we lost a
shoving match in Angola communists
threatened to come to power by peaceful
means in Italy and relations generally
have cooled with the Soviet Union in the
last few months so let me ask you first
what do you do about such cases as Italy
and secondly does this general drift
mean that we're moving back towards
something like an old Cold War
relationship with the Soviet Union I
don't believe we should move to a Cold
War relationship I think it's in the
best interest of the United States and
the world as a whole that the United
States negotiate rather than go back to
the Cold War relationship with the
Soviet Union
I don't look at the picture as Bleakley
as you have indicated in your question
mr. to it I believe that the United
States has had many successes in recent
years in recent months as far as the
communist movement is concerned we have
been successful in Portugal where a year
ago it looked like there was a very
great possibility that the Communists
would take over in Portugal it didn't
happen we have a democracy in Portugal
today a few months ago or I should say
maybe two years ago the Soviet Union
looked like they had continued strength
in the Middle East today
according to prime minister Rabine the
Soviet Union is weaker in the Middle
East than they have been in many many
years the facts are there the Soviet
Union relationship with Egypt is at a
low level the Soviet Union relationship
with Syria is at a very low point the
United States today
according to prime minister Rabine of
Israel is at a peak in its influence and
power in the Middle East but let's turn
for a minute to the southern African
operations that are now going on the
United States of America took the
initiative in southern Africa we wanted
to end the bloodshed in southern Africa
we wanted to have the right of
self-determination in southern Africa we
wanted to have majority rule with the
full protection of the rights of the
minority we wanted to preserve human
dignity in southern Africa we have taken
the initiative and in southern Africa
today the United States is trusted by
the black frontline nations and black
Africa the United States is trusted by
the other elements in southern Africa
the United States foreign policy under
this administration has been one of
progress and success and I believe that
instead of talking about Soviet progress
we can talk about
American successes and may I make an
observation part of the question you
asked mr. Truitt I don't believe that
it's in the best interest of the United
States and the NATO nations to have a
communist government in NATO mr. Carter
has indicated he would look with
sympathy to a communist government in
NATO I think that would destroy the
integrity and the strength of NATO and I
am totally opposed to it
unfortunately it just made a statement
it's not true I have never advocated a
communist government for Italy that
would obviously be a ridiculous thing
for anyone to do who wanted to be
president of this country I think that
this is a an instance for a deliberate
distortion and this is occurred also in
the question about defense as a matter
of fact I've never advocated any cut of
15 billion dollars in our defense budget
as a matter of fact mr. Ford has made a
political football out of the defense
budget about a year ago he cut the
Pentagon budget six point eight billion
dollars after he fired James Schlesinger
the political heat got so great that he
added back about three billion dollars
when Ronald Reagan won the Texas primary
election mr. Ford added back another one
and a half billion dollars immediately
before the Kansas City convention he
headed back another 1.8 billion dollars
in the defense budget and his own Office
of Management and Budget testified that
he had a three billion dollar cut
insurance added to the defense to budget
defense budget under the pressure from
the Pentagon obviously this is another
indication of trying to use the defense
budget for political purposes which he's
trying to do tonight now we went into
South Africa late after Great Britain
Rhodesia the black nations had been
trying to solve this problem for many
many years we didn't go in until right
before the election similar to what was
taking place in 1972 but mr. Kissinger
announced pieces at hand just before the
election at that time and we have
weakened our position and later because
the other countries in Europe supported
the democratic forces in Portugal long
before we did we stuck to the Portugal
dictatorships much longer than other
democracies did in this world mr.
bellari any questions for governor
Carter governor Carter much of what the
United States does abroad is done in the
name of the national interest what is
your concept of the national interest
what should the role of the United
States in the world be and in that
connection considering your limited
experience in foreign affairs and the
fact that you take some pride and be
Washington outsider don't you think it
would be appropriate for you to tell the
American voters before the election the
people that you would like to have in
key positions such as Secretary of State
Secretary of Defense national security
affairs advisor at the White House well
I'm not gonna name my cabinet before I
get elected I got a little place to go
before I start doing that but I have an
adequate background I believe I am a
graduate of the u.s. Naval Academy oath
first military graduate since so I so
now I've served as governor of Georgia
and have traveled extensively in foreign
countries in South America Central
America Europe the Middle East and in
Japan I've traveled the last 21 months
among the people of this country I've
talked to them and I've listened and
I've seen it firsthand in a very vivid
way the deep hurt this come to this
country in the aftermath of Vietnam and
Cambodia Chile and Pakistan and Angola
and Watergate CIA revelations what we
were formerly so proud of the strength
of our country its moral integrity the
representation in foreign affairs of
what our people are what our
Constitution stands for has been gone
and in the secrecy that has surrounded
our foreign policy in the last few years
the American people the Congress have
been excluded I believe I know what this
country ought to be I've been one who's
loved my nation as many Americans do and
I believe that there's no limit placed
on what we can be in the future if we
can harness its tremendous resources
militarily economically and the stature
of our people the meaning of a
constitution in the future every time
we've made a serious mistake in foreign
affairs it's been because the American
people have been excluded from the
process if we can just tell the
intelligence and ability the sound
common sense and a good judgment of the
American people we can once again have a
foreign policy to make us proud instead
of ashamed and I'm not going to exclude
the American people from that process in
the future as mr. forward in kitchen to
have done this is what it takes to have
a sound foreign policy
strong at home Spong defense permanent
commitments not betray the principles of
our country and involve the American
people into Congress in the shaping of a
foreign policy every time mr. Ford
speaks from a position of secrecy in
negotiations and secret and secret
treaties that have been pursued and
achieved in supporting dictatorships in
ignoring human rights we are weak and
the rest of the world knows it so these
are the ways that we can restore the
strength of our country and they don't
require a long experience in foreign
policy nobody has that except a
president who served a long time with
Secretary of State but my background my
experience my knowledge of the people of
this country my commitment to our
principles that don't change those are
the best bases to correct the horrible
mistakes of this administration and
restore our own country
to a position of leadership in the world
how specifically governor are you going
to bring the American people into the
decision-making process and in foreign
policy
what does that mean first of all I would
quit conducting the decision-making
process in secret as has been a
characteristic of mr. Kissinger and mr.
Ford in many instances we've made
agreements like in Vietnam that have
been revealed later on to our
embarrassment recently Ian Smith the
president of Rhodesia announced that he
had unequivocal commitments from mr.
Kissinger that he could not reveal the
American people don't know what those
commitments are we've seen in the past a
destruction of elected governments like
in Chile and the strong support of
military dictatorship there these kinds
of things have heard us very much I
would restore the concept of the
fireside chat which was an integral part
of the administration of Franklin
Roosevelt and I would also restore the
involvement of the Congress when Harry
Truman was president he was not afraid
to have a strong Secretary of Defense
Dean Acheson George Marshall was strong
secretaries of a state Cheeseman state
but he also made sure that there was a
bipartisan support the members of
Congress author Bannon Berg Walter
George were part of the process and
before our nation made a secret
agreement before we made a bluffing
statement we were sure that we had to
backing not only the President the
Secretary of State but also the Congress
and the people this is a responsibility
of the President and I think it's very
damaging to our country for mr. Ford to
have turned over this responsibility to
the Secretary of State President Warren
do you have a response Governor Carter
again contradicts himself he complains
about secrecy and yet he is quoted as
saying that in the attempt to find a
solution in the Middle East that he
would hold unpublicized meetings with
the Soviet Union
I presume for the purpose of imposing a
settlement on Israel and the Arab
nations but let me talk just a minute
about what we've done to avoid secrecy
in the Ford administration after the
United States took the initiative and
working with Israel and with Egypt and
achieving the Sinai to agreement and I'm
proud to say that not a single Egyptian
or Israeli soldier has lost his life
since the signing of the Sinai agreement
but at the time that I submitted the
sinai agreement to the Congress of the
United States I submitted every single
document that was applicable to the
Sinai to agreement it was the most
complete documentation by any president
of any agreement signed by a president
on behalf of the United States now as
far as meeting with the Congress is
concerned during the 24 months that I've
been the president of the United States
I have averaged better than one meeting
a month with responsible groups or
committees of the Congress both House
and Senate the Secretary of State has
appeared in the several years that he's
been the secretary before
80 different committee hearings in the
house and in the Senate the Secretary of
State has made better than 50 speeches
all over the United States
explaining American foreign policy I
have made myself at least 10 speeches in
various parts of the country where I
have discussed with the American people
defense and foreign policy mister
frankel a question for President Ford
this president I'd like to explore a
little more deeply our relationship with
the Russians they used to brag back in
Khrushchev's day that because of their
greater patience and because of our
greed for business deals that they would
sooner or later get the better of us
is it possible that despite some
setbacks in the Middle East they've
proved their point our allies in France
and Italy are now flirting with
communism we've recognized a permanent
communist regime in East Germany we
virtually signed in Helsinki an
agreement that the Russians have
dominance in Eastern Europe we bailed
out Soviet agriculture with our huge
grain sales we've given them large loans
access to our best technology and if the
Senate hadn't interfered with the
Jackson amendment maybe you would have
given them even larger loans is that
what you call a two-way street of
traffic in Europe I believe that we have
negotiated with the Soviet Union since
I've been president from a position of
strength
and let me cite several examples shortly
after I became president in December of
1974 I met with general secretary
Brezhnev in Vladivostok and we agreed to
a mutual cap on the ballistic missile
launchers at a ceiling of 2,400 which
means that the Soviet Union if that
becomes a permanent agreement we'll have
to make a reduction in their launchers
that they now have or plan to have I
negotiated at Vladivostok with mr.
Brezhnev a limitation on the Mervin of
their ballistic missiles at a figure of
1320 which is the first time that any
president has achieved a cap either on
launchers or on
it seems to me that we can go from there
to the grain sales the grain sales have
been a benefit to American agriculture
we have achieved a five and
three-quarter year sale of a minimum of
six million metric tons which means that
they have already bought about four
million metric tons this year and are
bound to buy another two million metric
tons to take the grain and corn and
wheat that the American farmers have
produced in order to have full
production and these grain sales to the
Soviet Union have helped us tremendously
in meeting the costs of the additional
oil and the oil that we have bought from
overseas if we turn to Helsinki I'm glad
you raised it mr. Franco in the case of
Helsinki 35 nations signed an agreement
including the Secretary of State for the
Vatican
I can't under any circumstances believe
that the his Holiness the Pope would
agree by signing that agreement that the
35 nations have turned over to the
Warsaw Pact nations the domination of
Eastern Europe it just isn't true and if
mr. Carter alleges that his holiness by
signing that has done it he is totally
inaccurate now what has been
accomplished by the Helsinki agreement
number one we have an agreement where
they notify us and we notify them of any
military maneuvers that are to be
undertaken they have done it in both
cases where they've done so there is no
Soviet domination of Eastern Europe and
there never will be under a foreign
administration
Hey I'm sorry I could I just filed it
under stand you to say sir that the
Russians are not using Eastern Europe as
their own sphere of influence and
occupying most of the countries there
and and making sure with their troops
that it's a that it's a communist zone
whereas on our side of the line the
Italians and the French are still
flirting with I don't believe mr. Franco
that the Yugoslavians consider
themselves dominated by the Soviet Union
I don't believe that the Romanians
consider themselves dominated by the
Soviet Union I don't believe that the
poles consider themselves dominated by
the Soviet Union each of those countries
is independent autonomous it has its own
territorial integrity and the United
States does not concede that those
countries are under the domination of
the Soviet Union as a matter of fact I
visited Poland Yugoslavia and Romania to
make certain that the people of those
countries understood that the president
of the United States and the people of
the United States are dedicated to their
independence their autonomy and their
freedom Governor Carter never responds
well in the first place I'm not
criticizing his Holiness the Pope I was
talking about mr. forward the young fact
is that secrecy has surrounded the
decisions made by the Ford
administration in the case for the
Helsinki agreement it may have been a
good agreement at the beginning but we
have failed to enforce the so-called
basket 3-part which ensures a right of
people to migrate to join the families
to be free to speak out the Soviet Union
is still jamming Radio Free Europe Radio
Radio Free Europe is being jammed we've
also seen a very serious problem with
the so-called Sun and felt document
which apparently mr. Ford is just
endorsed which said it as an organic
linkage between the Eastern European
countries in the Soviet Union
and I would like to see mr. Ford
convince the polish Americans and the
Czech Americans and the Hungarian
Americans in this country that those
countries don't live under the
domination and supervision of the Soviet
Union behind the Iron Curtain we also
have seen mr. Ford exclude himself from
access to the public he hasn't had a
tough cross-examination type press
conference in over 30 days one press
conference he had without sound he's
also shown a weakness in yielding to
pressure the Soviet Union for instance
put pressure on mr. Ford and he refused
to see a symbol of human freedom
recognized around the world Alexander
Solzhenitsyn the Arabs have put pressure
on mr. Ford and he's yielded and has
permitted a boycott by the Arab
countries of American businesses who
trade with Israel who have American Jews
owning or taking part in the management
of American companies his own Secretary
of Commerce had to be subpoenaed by the
Congress to reveal the names of
businesses who was subject to this
boycott they didn't volunteer the
information he had to be subpoenaed and
the last thing I'd like to say is this
this grain deal with the Soviet Union in
72 was terrible and mr. Ford made up for
it with three embargoes one against our
own ally in Japan that's not the way to
run our foreign policy including
international trade mr. true had a
question for governor Carter code I'd
like to pick up on that point actually
and on your appeal for a greater measure
of American idealism in foreign affairs
foreign affairs come home to the
American public pretty much in such
issues as oil embargos and grain sales
that sort of thing would you be willing
to to risk an oil embargo in order to
promote human rights and Iran Saudi
Arabia withhold arms from Saudi Arabia
for the same purpose why I think you
matter of fact you've perhaps answered
this final point but would you with
whole grain from the Soviet Union in
order to promote civil rights in the in
the Soviet Union
I would never sing loud food as a trade
embargo item if I ever decided to impose
an embargo because of a crisis and in
actual relationships it would include
all shipments of all equipment for
instance if the Arab countries ever
again declare an embargo against our
nation on oil I would consider that not
a military but an economic declaration
of war and I would respond instantly and
in kind I would not ship that Arab
country anything no weapons no spare
parts for weapons no all drilling rigs
no all pipe no nothing I wouldn't think
about just food another thing I'd like
to say is this in our international
trade as I said in my opening statement
we have become the arms merchants of the
world when this Republican
administration came into office we were
shipping about 1 billion dollars worth
of arms overseas now 10 to 12 billion
dollars worth of arms overseas to
countries it quite often use these
weapons to fight each other the shift in
emphasis has been very disturbing to me
speaking about the Middle East under the
last democratic administration 60% of
all weapons that went into the Middle
East but for Israel nowadays 75% were
for Israel before now 60% go to the Arab
countries and this does not include Iran
if you include Iran our present shipment
of weapons to the Middle East only 20%
goes to Israel this is a deviation from
idealism
it's a deviation from a commitment to
our major ally in the Middle East which
is Israel
it's a yielding to economic pressure on
the part of the Arabs on the oil issue
and it's also a tremendous indication
that under the Ford administration we
have not addressed the energy policy
adequately we still have no
comprehensive energy policy in this
country and it's an overall sign of
weakness when we're weak at home in
economically high unemployment high
inflation a confused government a
wasteful defense establishment this
encourages the kind of pressure that's
been put on us successfully it would
have been inconceivable 10 15 years ago
for us to be brought to our knees with
an Arab oil embargo but it was done
three years ago and they're still
putting pressure on us
from the Arab countries to our discredit
around the world these are the
weaknesses that I see and I believe it's
not just a matter of idealism it's a
matter of being tough it's a matter of
being strong it's a matter of being
consistent our priorities want to be
first of all to meet our own military
needs secondly to meet the needs of our
allies and friends and only then should
we ship military equipment to foreign
countries as a matter of fact Iran is
going to get 80 l14 before we even meet
our own air force orders for air 14s and
the shipment of Sprint's class
destroyers to Iran are much more highly
sophisticated than a Spruance class
destroyers that are present being
delivered to our own Navy this is
ridiculous and it ought to be changed
governor let me pursue that if I may if
I understand you correctly you would in
fact use my examples with hold arms from
Iran and Saudi Arabia even if the risk
was an oil embargo and if they should be
securing those arms from somewhere else
and then if the embargo came then you
would respond in kind do I have it
correctly if Iran is not an Arab
countries you know if it's a Moslem
country but if Saudi Arabia should
declare an oil embargo against us then I
would consider that an economic
declaration of war and I would make sure
that the Saudis understood this ahead of
time so there would be no doubt in their
mind I think under those circumstances
they would refrain from pushing us to
our knees as they did in 1973 with our
previous oil embargo president foon
governor Carter apparently doesn't
realize that since I've been president
we have sold to the Israelis over four
billion dollars in military hardware we
have made available to the Israelis over
45% of the total economic and military
aid since the establishment of Israel 27
years ago so the Ford administration has
done a good job in helping our good ally
Israel
and we're dedicated to the survival and
security of Israel
I believe that Governor Carter doesn't
realize the need and necessity for arms
sales to Iran he indicates he would not
make those Iran is bordered very
extensively by the Soviet Union
Iran has Iraq as one of its neighbors
the Soviet Union and the Communist
dominated government of Iraq are
neighbours of Iran and Iran is an ally
of the United States it's my strong
feeling that we ought to sell arms to
Iran for its own national security and
as an ally a strong ally of the United
States the history of our relationship
with Iran goes back to the days of
President Truman when he decided that it
was vitally necessary for our own
security as well as that of Iran that we
should help that country and Iran has
been a good ally in 1973 when there was
an oil embargo Iran did not participate
Iran continued to sell oil to the United
States I believe that it's in our
interest and in the interest of Israel
and Iran and Saudi Arabia for the United
States to sell arms to those countries
it's for their security as well as ours
mr. valeriani a question for president
thorn
mr. president the policy of your
administration is to normalize relations
with mainland China and that means
establishing at some point full
diplomatic relations and obviously doing
something about the mutual defense
treaty with Taiwan if you are elected
will you move to establish full
diplomatic relations with Peking and
will you abrogate the mutual defense
treaty with Taiwan and as a corollary
would you provide mainland China with
military equipment if the Chinese were
to ask for
our relationship with the People's
Republic of China is based upon the
Shanghai communique of 1972 and that
communique calls for the normalization
of relations between the United States
and the People's Republic it doesn't set
a times schedule it doesn't make a
determination as to how that
relationship should be achieved in
relationship to our current diplomatic
recognition and obligations to the
Taiwanese government the Shanghai
communique does say that the differences
between the People's Republic on the one
hand and Taiwan on the other shall be
settled by peaceful means the net result
is this administration and during my
time as the president for the next four
years we will continue to move for
normalization of relations in the
traditional sense and we will insist
that the disputes between Taiwan and the
People's Republic be settled peacefully
as was agreed in the Shanghai communique
of 1972 the Ford administration will not
let down will not eliminate or forget
our obligation to the people of Taiwan
we feel that there must be a continued
obligation to the people the some 19 or
20 million people in Taiwan and as we
move during the next four years those
will be the policies of this
administration and sir the military
equipment for the mainland Chinese there
is no policy of this government to give
to the People's Republic or to sell to
the People's Republic of China military
equipment I do not believe that we the
United States should sell give or
otherwise transfer military hardware to
the People's Republic of China or any
other
in this nation such as the Soviet Union
and the like
governor Carter I'd like to go back just
one moment to the previous question
where mr. Ford I think confuse the issue
by trying to say that we are shipping
Israel 40% of our a as a matter of fact
during this current year are we're
shipping Iran I have contracted to ship
to Iran about seven and a half billion
dollars worth of arms and also to Saudi
Arabia about seven and a half billion
dollars worth of arms also in 1975 we
almost brought Israel to their knees
after the Yom Kippur War by the so
called reassessment of our relationship
to Israel we in effect tried to make
Israel to scapegoat for the problems in
the Middle East and this weakened our
relationship with Israel a great deal
and put a cloud on the total commitment
that our people feel toward the Israelis
they ought to be a clear unequivocal
commitment without change to Israel in
the 40s I think we need to continue to
be strong and I would certainly pursue
the normalization of relationships with
the People's Republic of China we open
up a great opportunity in 1972 which is
pretty well been fretted all right but
Fred it away under mr. Ford that ought
to be your constant or inclination to it
to a friendship but I would never let
that friendship with the People's
Republic of China stand in a way off the
preservation of the independence and
freedom other people on Taiwan mr.
Fraenkel a question for governor Carter
governor we always seem in our elections
and maybe in between to to argue about
who can be tougher in the world give or
take a few billion dollars give or take
one weapon systems our leading
politicians and I think you two
gentlemen seem to settle roughly on the
same strategy in the world at roughly
the same Pentagon budget cost how bad do
things have to get in our own economy or
how much backwardness and hunger would
have taken the world to persuade you
that our national security and our
survival required very drastic cut
in arms spending and dramatic new
efforts in other directions well always
in the past we've had an ability to have
a strong defense and also have to have a
strong domestic economy and also to be
strong in our reputation and influence
within the community of nations these
characteristics of our country have been
endangered under mr. Ford we are no
longer respected in a showdown vote in
the United Nations or in any other
international council we're lucky to get
20% of the other nations to vote with us
our allies feel that we've neglected
them the so-called Nixon shock against
Japan may weaken our relationships there
under this administration we've also had
an inclination to keep separate the
European countries thinking that if they
are separate then we can dominate them
and proceed with our secret Lone Ranger
type diplomatic efforts I would also
like to point out that we in this
country have let our economy go down a
drain the worst inflation since the
Great Depression the highest
unemployment of any developed nation of
the world we have a higher unemployment
rate in this country than Great Britain
than West Germany our unemployment rate
is twice as high as it is in Italy it's
three or four times as high as it is in
Japan and that terrible circumstance in
this country is exported overseas we
comprise about 30% of the world's
economic trade power influence and when
we wreak at home weaker than all our
allies that weakness weakens a whole
free world so strong economy is very
important another thing that we need to
do is to re-establish the good
relationships that we ought to have
between the United States and our
natural allies and friends they've felt
neglected and using that base of
strength and using the idealism the
honesty the predictability the
commitment the integrity of our own
country
that's where our strength lies and that
would permit us to deal with the
developing nations in a position of
strength under this administration we've
had a continuation of the so called
balance of power politics where
everything is looked on as a struggle
between us on the one side the Soviet
Union on the other our allies the
smaller countries get trampled in the
rush what we need is to try to seek
individualize bilateral relationships
with countries regardless of their signs
and to establish world order politics
which means that we want to preserve
peace through strength we also want to
revert back to the stature and the
respect that I country had in previous
administrations now I can't say when
this can come but I can guarantee you it
will not come if Gerald Ford is
reelected and this present policy has
continued it will come if I'm elected I
hear you right sir you're saying guns
and butter both but President Johnson
also had trouble keeping up both Vietnam
and his domestic programs I was really
asking when do they the needs of the
cities and our own needs and those of
other back written and even more needy
countries and societies around the world
take precedence over some of our
military spending ever well let me say
very quickly that under President
Johnson in spite of the massive
investment in the Vietnam War he turned
over a balanced budget to mr. Nixon the
unemployment rate was less than 4% the
inflation rate under Kennedy and Johnson
was about 2% one-third what it is under
this administration so we did have at
that time with good management the
ability to do both I don't think anybody
can say that Johnson and Kennedy
neglected the poor and the destitute
people in this country all around the
world but I can say this the number one
responsibility of any president above
all else is to guarantee the security of
our nation an ability to be free of the
threat of attack or blackmail and to
carry out our obligations to our allies
and friends and to carry out a
legitimate foreign policy they must go
hand in hand but the security of this
nation it's got to come first
president's point let me say very
categorically
you cannot maintain the security and the
strength of the United States with the
kind of defense budget cuts that
Governor Carter has indicated in 1975 he
wanted to cut the budget 15 billion
dollars he's now down to a figure of
five to seven billion dollars reductions
of that kind will not permit the United
States to be strong enough to deter
aggression and maintain the peace
governor Carter apparently doesn't know
the facts as soon as I became president
I initiated meetings with the NATO heads
of state and met with them in Brussels
to discuss how we could improve the
defense relationship in Western Europe
in November of 1975 I met with the
leaders of the five industrial nations
in France for the purpose of seeing what
we could do acting together to meet the
problems of the coming recession in
Puerto Rico this year I met with six of
the leading industrial nations heads of
state to meet the problem of inflation
so we would be able to solve it before
it got out of hand I have met with the
heads of government bilaterally as well
as multilaterally our relations with
Japan have never been better
I was the first United States president
to visit Japan and we had the Emperor of
Japan here this past year and the net
result is Japan and the United States
are working more closely together now
that at any time in the history of our
relationship you can go around the world
and let me take Israel for example just
recently president Rabine said that our
relations were never better
mr. Truitt to question for President
Ford mr. president you referred earlier
to your meeting with mr. Brezhnev at
Vladivostok
1974 at you agreed on that occasion to
try to achieve another strategic arms
limitation salt agreement within the
year nothing happened in 1975 are not
very much publicly at least and those
talks are still dragging things got
quieter is the current season approached
is there is there a bit of politics
involved there perhaps on both sides are
perhaps more important our interim
weapons developments and I'm thinking of
such things as a cruise missile and the
Soviet SS 20 intermediate range rocket
making salt irrelevant by passing the
salt negotiations first we have to
understand that salt 1 expires October
3rd 1977 mr. Brezhnev and I met in
Vladivostok in December of 1974 for the
purpose of trying to take the initial
step so we could have a salt ii
agreement that would go to 1985 as i
indicated earlier we did agree on a
2,400 limitation on launchers of
ballistic missiles that would mean a
cutback in the soviet program it would
not interfere with our own program at
the same time we put a limitation of
1320 on MERS our technicians have been
working since that time in Geneva
trying to put into technical language a
an agreement that can be verified by
both parties in the meantime there has
developed the problem of the Soviet
backfire their high-performance aircraft
which they say is not a long-range
aircraft in which some of our people say
is a intercontinental aircraft in the
interim there has been the development
on our part primarily the cruise
missiles cruise missiles that could be
launched from land-based mobile
installations cruise missiles it could
be lanced a law
from high-performance aircraft like the
b-52s or the B ones which I hope we
proceed with cruise missiles which could
be launched from either surface or
submarine naval vessels those gray area
weapon systems are creating some
problems in the agreement for assault to
negotiation but I can say that I am
dedicated to proceeding and I met just
last week with the foreign minister of
the Soviet Union and he indicated to me
that the Soviet Union was interested in
narrowing the differences and making a
realistic and a sound compromise I hope
and trust in the best interest of both
countries and in the best interest of
all people throughout this globe that
the Soviet Union and the United States
can make a mutually beneficial agreement
because if we do not and salt 1 expires
on October 3 1977 you will unleash again
and all-out nuclear arms race with the
potential of a nuclear holocaust of
unbelievable dimensions so it's the
obligation of the President to do just
that and I intend to do so
mr. president let me follow that up by
I'll submit that the cruise missile adds
a whole new dimension to the to the arms
competition and then cite a statement by
your office to the Arms Control
Association a few days ago in which you
said that the cruise missile might
eventually be included in a
comprehensive arms limitation agreement
but that in the meantime it was an
essential part of the American strategic
arsenal now may I assume from that that
you're tending to exclude the cruise
missile from the next salt agreement or
is it still negotiable in that context I
believe that
the cruise missiles which we are now
developing in research and development
across the spectrum from air from the
sea or from the land can be included
within a salt - agreement they are a new
weapon system that has a great potential
both conventional and nuclear armed at
the same time we have to make certain
that the Soviet Union's backfire which
they claim is not an intercontinental
aircraft in which some of our people
contend is must also be included if we
are to get the kind of an agreement
which is in the best interest of both
countries a really believe that if it's
far better for us and for the Soviet
Union and more importantly for the
people around the world that these two
superpowers find an answer for assault -
agreement before October 3 1977 I think
good will on both parts hard bargaining
by both parties and a reasonable
compromise will be in the best interest
of all parties governor Carter well mr.
Ford acts like he's running for
president for the first time he's been
in office two years and there has been
absolutely no progress made toward a new
salt agreement he has learned the date
of the expiration of salt one apparently
we've seen in this world a development
of a tremendous threat to us as a
nuclear engineer myself I know the
limitations and capabilities of atomic
power I also know that as far as the
human beings on this earth are concern
that the non-proliferation of atomic
weapons is number one only the last few
days with the election approaching as
mr. Ford taken any interest in a
non-proliferation movement I advocated
last May in a speech at the United
Nations that we move immediately as a
nation to declare a complete moratorium
on the testing
of all nuclear devices both weapons and
peaceful devices that we not ship any
more atomic fuel to a country that
refuses to comply with strict control
over the waste which can be reprocessed
into explosives
I've also advocated that we stop the
sale by Germany and France processing
plants to Pakistan in Brazil mr. food
hasn't moved on this we also need to
provide an adequate supply of enriched
uranium mr. Ford again under pressure
from the Atomic Energy Lobby has
insisted that this reprocessing or other
Richmond be done by private industry and
not by the existing or government plants
this kind of confusion and absence of
leadership has let us drift now for two
years with a constantly increasing
threat of atomic weapons throughout the
world we now have five nations that have
atomic bombs that we know about if we
continue under mr. Ford's policy by 1985
or 90 we'll have 20 nations that have
the capability of exploding atomic
weapons this has got to be stopped that
is one of the major challenges and major
undertakings that I will assume as a
next president mr. valeriani a question
for Governor Carter
governor Carter earlier tonight you said
America is not strong anymore America is
not respected anymore I feel I must ask
you do you really believe that the
United States is not the strongest
country in the world do you really
believe that the United States is not
the most respected country in the world
or is that just campaign rhetoric no
it's not just campaign rhetoric I think
that militarily we are strong as any
nation on earth I think we've got to
stay that way and continue to increase
our capabilities to meet any potential
threat but as far as strength derived
from commitment to principles as far as
strength derived from the unity within
our country as far as strength derived
from the people the Congress the
Secretary of State the president sharing
in the evolution and carrying out of a
foreign policy as far as strength
derived from the respect of our own
allies and friends they're a sure
that we will be staunch in our
commitment that we will not deviate and
it will give them adequate attention as
far as a strength derived from doing
what's right
caring for the pool providing food
becoming the breadbasket of the world
instead of the arms merchants of the
world in those respects we're not strong
also we'll never be strong again
overseas unless we're strong at home and
with our economy and such terrible
disarray and getting worse by the month
we've got 500,000 more Americans
unemployed today than we had three
months ago we've got two and a half
million more Americans out of work now
then we have mr. Porter koffice this
kind of deterioration in our economic
strength is bound to weaken us around
the world and we not only have problems
at home but we export those problems
overseas so as far as the respect of our
own people toward our own government as
far as participation in the shaping for
concepts and commitments as far as the
trust of our country among the nations
of the world is for its dependence of
our country in meeting the needs and
obligations that we've expressed our
allies as far as a respect of our
country even among our potential
adversaries we are weak potentially we
are strong under this administration
that strength has not been realized
President Ford governor Carter brags
about the unemployment during Democratic
administrations and condemns the
unemployment at the present time I must
remind him that we're at peace and
during the period that he brags about
unemployment being low the United States
was at war now let me correct one other
comment that Governor Carter has made I
have recommended to the Congress that we
develop the uranium enrichment plant at
Portsmouth Ohio which is a publicly
owned US government facility and have
indicated that the private program which
would follow on in Alabama is one that
may or may not be constructive but I am
committed to the one at Portsmouth Ohio
the governor also talks about morality
in foreign policy the foreign policy of
the United States meets the highest
standards of morality
what is more moral than peace and the
United States is at peace today
what is more moral in foreign policy
than food conference in Rome in 1974
when the United States committed six
million metric tons of food over 60% of
the food committed for the disadvantaged
and underdeveloped nations of the world
the Ford administration wants to
eradicate hunger and disease in our
underdeveloped countries throughout the
world
what is more moral than for the United
States under the Ford administration to
take the lead in southern Africa in the
Middle East
those are initiatives in foreign policy
which are of the highest moral standard
and that is indicative of the foreign
policy of this country mr. Fraenkel a
question for President Ford mr.
president can we stick with morality ax
where a lot of people seems to cover a
bunch of sins mr. Nixon and mr.
Kissinger used to tell us that instead
of morality we had to worry in the world
about living with and letting live all
kinds of governments that we really
didn't like North and South Korean
dictator's Chilean fascists Chinese
Communists Iranian emperors and so on
they said the only way to get by in a
wicked world was to treat others on the
basis of how they treated us and not how
they treated their own people but more
recently we seem to have taken a
different tack we've seem to decided
that it is part of our business to tell
the Rhodesians for instance that the way
they're treating their own black people
is wrong and they've got to change their
government we've put pressure on them we
were rather liberal in our advice to the
Italians as to how to vote
is this a new Ford foreign-policy in the
making can we expect that you are now
going to turn to South Africa and force
them to change their government to
intervene in similar ways to end the
bloodshed as you called it say in Chile
or Chilean prisons and to throw our
weight around for the for the values
that that we hold dear in the world I
believe that our foreign policy must
express the highest standards of
morality and the initiatives that we
took in southern Africa are the best
examples of what this administration is
doing and will continue to do in the
next four years if the United States had
not moved when we did in southern Africa
there's no doubt there would have been
an acceleration of bloodshed in that
tragic part of the world if we have not
taken our initiative it's very very
possible that the government of Rhodesia
would have been overrun and that the
Soviet Union and the Cubans would have
dominated southern Africa so the United
States seeking to preserve the principle
of self-determination to eliminate the
possibility of bloodshed to protect the
rights of the minority as we insisted
upon the rights of the majority
I believe followed the good conscience
of the American people in foreign policy
and I believe that we have used our
skill Secretary of State Kissinger has
done a superb job
in working with the black African
nations of so-called front-line nations
he has done a superb job in getting the
prime minister of South Africa mr.
Forester to agree that the time had come
for a solution to the problem of
Rhodesia secretary Kissinger in his
meeting with Prime Minister Smith of
Rhodesia was able to convince him that
it was in the best interests of whites
as well as blacks in
rhodesia to find an answer for a
transitional government and then a
majority government this is a perfect
example of the kind of leadership that
the United States under this
administration has taken and I can
assure you that this administration will
follow that high moral principle in our
future efforts in foreign policy
including our efforts in the Middle East
where it is vitally important because
the Middle East is the crossroads of the
world there have been more disputes and
it's an area where there's more
volatility than any other place in the
world but because Arab nations and the
Israelis trust the United States we were
able to take the lead in the cyanide to
agreement and I can assure you that the
United States will have the leadership
role in moving toward a comprehensive
settlement of the Middle Eastern
problems I hope and trust as soon as
possible and we will do it with the
highest moral principles mr. president
just clarify one point there are lots of
majorities in the world that feel
they're being pushed around by minority
governments and are you saying they can
now expect to look to us for not just
good cheer but throwing our weight on
their side in South Africa or on Taiwan
or in Chile to help change their
governments as in Rhodesia I would hope
that as we move to one area of the world
from another and the United States must
not spread itself too thinly that was
one of the problems that helped to
create the circumstances in Vietnam but
as we as a nation find that we are asked
by the various parties either one nation
against another or individual within a
nation that the United States will take
the leadership and try to resolve the
differences let me take South Korea as
an example
I have personally told president Pak
that the United States does not condone
the kind of repressive measures that he
has taken in that country but I think in
all fairness and equity we have to
recognize the problem that South Korea
has on the north they have North Korea
with 500,000 well-trained well-equipped
troops they are supported by the
People's Republic of China they are
supported by the Soviet Union South
Korea faces a very delicate situation
now the United States in this case this
administration has recommended a year
ago and we have reiterated it again this
year that the United States South Korea
North Korea and the People's Republic of
China sit down at a conference table to
resolve the problems of the Korean
Peninsula this is a leadership role that
the United States under this
administration is carrying out and if we
do it and I think the opportunities and
the possibilities are getting better we
will have solved many of the internal
domestic problems that exist in South
Korea at the present time
governor Carter I notice that mr. Ford
didn't comment on the prisons in Chile
this isn't a typical example maybe of
many others for this administration
overthrew an elected government and
helped to establish a military
dictatorship this has not been an
ancient history story last year on the
Ford of all the food for peace that went
to South America eighty-five percent
went to the military dictatorship in
Chile another point I want to make is
this he says we have to move from one
area of the world to another
that's one of the problems with this
administration's so-called shuttle
diplomacy for the secretary of states in
one country there are almost 150 others
that are wondering what we're going to
do next what will be the next secret
agreement we don't have a crop
understandable foreign policy that deals
with world problems or even regional
problems another thing to concern me was
what mr. Ford said about unemployment at
insinuating that under Johnson and
Kennedy that unemployment could only be
held down when this country is at war
Karl Marx said that the free enterprise
system in a democracy can only continue
to exist when they are at war or
preparing for war Karl Marx was a
grandfather of communism I don't agree
with that statement I hope mr. Ford
doesn't either he has put pressure on
the Congress and I don't believe mr.
Ford would even deny this to hold up on
non-proliferation legislation until the
Congress agreed for an eight billion
dollar program for private industry to
start producing enriched uranium and the
last thing I want to make is this it
talks about peace and I'm thankful for
peace we were peaceful but mr. Ford went
into office but he and mr. Kissinger and
others tried to start a new Vietnam in
Angola and it was only the outcry of the
American people and the Congress when
their secret deal was discovered they
prevented our renewed involvement in
that conflagration which was taking
place there gentlemen I'm sorry to say
we do not have time enough for two
complete sequences of questions we now
have only 12 minutes left therefore I
would like to ask for shorter questions
and shorter answers and we also will
drop the follow-up question each
candidate may still respond of course to
the others answered mr. Truitt question
for governor Carter governor Carter
before this event the most
communications I received concern Panama
is would you as president be prepared to
sign a treaty which at a fixed date
yielded administrative and economic
control of the Canal Zone and shared
defense which as I understand it is the
position the United States took in 1974
well here again the Panamanian question
is one that's been confused by mr. Ford
he had directed his diplomatic
relationship well our representative to
yield to the Panamanians forum
sovereignty oval the Panama Canal Zone
at the end of a certain period of time
but mr. Reagan raised this a question in
Florida mr. food not only disavowed his
instructions
but he also even dropped parenthetically
the use of the word date time I would
never give up complete control or
practical control of the Panama Canal
Zone but I would continue to negotiate
with the Phantom minions when the
original treaty was signed back in the
early 1900s when Theodore Roosevelt was
president Panama retained sovereignty
over the Panama Canal Zone we retain
control as though we had sovereignty now
I would be willing to go ahead with
negotiations I believe that we could
share more fully responsibilities for
the Panama Canal Zone with Panama I
would be willing to continue to raise
the payment for shipment of goods
through the Panama Canal Zone
I might even be willing to reduce to
some degree our military emplacements in
the Panama Canal Zone but I would not
relinquish practical control of the
Panama Canal Zone in determine the
foreseeable future president thorn the
United States must and will maintain
complete access to the Panama Canal the
United States must maintain a defense
capability of the Panama Canal and the
United States will maintain our national
security interest in the Panama Canal
the negotiations for the Panama Canal
started under President Johnson and have
continued up to the present time
I believe those negotiations should
continue but there are certain
guidelines that must be followed and
I've just defined them let me take just
a minute to comment on something that
governor Carter said an on
new non-proliferation in May of 1975 I
call for a conference of Nuclear
Suppliers that conference has met six
times in May of this year
governor Carter took the first
initiative approximately 12 months after
I had taken my initiative a year ago mr.
valeriani a question for a president for
mr. president the Government Accounting
Office has just put out a report
suggesting that you shot from the hip
and the mayagez rescue mission and
that you ignored diplomatic messages
saying that a peaceful solution was in
prospect why didn't you do more
diplomatically at the time and a related
question did the White House try to
prevent the release of that report the
White House did not prevent the release
of that report on July 12th of this year
we gave full permission for the release
of that report I was very disappointed
in the fact that the GAO released that
report because I think it interjected
political partisan politics at the
present time but let me comment on the
report somebody who sits in Washington
DC 18 months after the mayagez
incident can be a very good grandstand
quarterback and let me make another
observation this morning I got a call
from the skipper of the mayagez he was
furious because he told me that it was
the action of me
President Ford that saved the lives of
the crew of the mayagez and I can
assure you that if we had not taken the
strong and forceful action that we did
we would have been criticized very very
severely for sitting back and not moving
captain Miller is thankful the crew is
thankful we did the right thing
it seems to me that those who sit in
Washington 18 months after the incident
are
not the best judges of the
decision-making process that had to be
made by the National Security Council
and by myself at the time the incident
was developing in the Pacific let me
assure you that we made every possible
overture to the People's Republic of
China and through them to the Cambodian
government we made diplomatic protests
to the Cambodian government through the
United Nations every possible diplomatic
means was utilized but at the same time
I had a responsibility and so did the
National Security Council to meet the
problem at hand and we handled it
responsibly and I think captain Miller's
testimony to that effect is the best
evidence
governor Carter
well I'm reluctant to comment on the
recent report I haven't read it I think
the American people have only one
requirement that the facts about
marriage where's be given to them
accurately and completely mr. Ford has
been there for 18 months he had the fact
of release today
immediately after the Merguez incident I
understand that the report today is
accurate mr. Ford has said I believe
that it was accurate and that the White
House made no attempt to block the
issuing of that report I don't know if
that's exactly accurate or not I
understand that both the Secretary of
Department of State and the Defense
Department have approved the accuracy of
today's report on yesterday's report and
also the National Security Agency I
don't know what was right of what was
wrong or what was done the only thing I
believe is that whatever their knowledge
was that mr. Ford had should have been
given to the American people 18 months
ago immediately after the mine crash so
interesting occurred this is what the
American people want when something
happens that endangers our security or
when something happens that threatens
our stature in the world or when
American people or endangered by the
actions of a foreign country just 40
sailors on the Marg where's we obviously
have to move aggressively and quickly to
rescue them but then after the immediate
action is taken I believe the president
has an obligation to tell the American
people the truth and not wait 18 months
later for the report to be issued
gentlemen at this time we have time for
only two very short questions mr.
Fraenkel a question for governor Carter
governor Carter if the price of gaining
influence among the Arabs is closing our
eyes a little bit to their boycott
against Israel how would you handle that
I believe that the boycott of American
businesses by the Arab countries because
those businesses trade with Israel well
because they have American Jews who are
owners or directors in the company is an
absolute disgrace this is the first time
that I remember in the history of our
country when we've got a foreign country
circumvent or change our Bill of Rights
I'll do everything I can as president to
stop the boycott of American businesses
by the Arab countries it's not a matter
of diplomacy or trade with me it's a
matter of morality and I don't believe
that there are countries will pursue it
when we have a strong president who will
protect the integrity of our country the
commitment of our Constitution and Bill
of Rights and protect people in this
country who happen to be Jews it may
later be Catholics it may be it later be
Baptist who are threatened by some
foreign country but we ought to stand
staunch and I think it's a disgrace it's
so far mr. Ford's administration has
blocked the passage of legislation they
would have revealed by law every
instance of the boycott and it would
have prevented the boycott from
continuing President Ford again governor
Carter is in Akron
the Arab boycott action was first taken
in 1952 and in November of 1975 I was
the first president to order the
executive branch to take action
affirmative action through the
Department of Commerce and other cabinet
departments to make certain that no
American businessman or business
organization should discriminate against
Jews because of an Arab boycott and I
might add that my administration and I'm
very proud of it is the first
administration that has taken an
antitrust action
against companies in this country that
have allegedly cooperated with the Arab
boycott
just on Monday of this week I signed a
tax bill that included an amendment that
would prevent companies in the United
States from taking a tax deduction if
they have in any way whatsoever
cooperated with the Arab boycott and
last week when we were trying to get the
export administration act through the
Congress necessary legislation my
administration went to Capitol Hill and
tried to convince the House and the
Senate that we should have an amendment
on that legislation which would take
strong and effective action against
those who participate or cooperate with
the Arab a boycott one other point
because the Congress failed to act I am
going to announce tomorrow that the
Department of Commerce will disclose
those companies that have participated
in the Arab boycott this is something
that we can do the Congress failed to do
it and we intend to do it mr. Truitt a
very brief question for President Ford
mr. president if you get the accounting
of missing-in-action you want from North
Vietnam or from Vietnam I'm sorry now
would you then be prepared to reopen
negotiations for a restoration of
relations with that country let me
restate our policy as long as Vietnam
North Vietnam does not give us a full
and complete accounting of our missing
in action I will never go along with the
admission of Vietnam to the United
Nations if they do give us a bonafide
complete accounting of the 800m IAS then
I believe that the United States should
begin negotiations for the admission of
Vietnam to the United Nations but not
until they have given us the full
counting of our M IAS Governor Carter
one of the most embarrassing failures of
the Ford administration and one that
touches specifically on human rights is
his refusal to a point a Presidential
Commission to go to Vietnam to go to
Laos to go to Cambodia and try to trade
for the release of information about
those who are missing in action in those
Wars this is what the families of mas
want so far mr. Ford has not done it
we've had several fragmentary efforts by
members of the Congress and Bryan by
private citizens several months ago the
Vietnam government said we are ready to
sit down and negotiate for a lease of
information on in my age so far mr. Ford
has not responded I also would never
normalize relationships with Vietnam nor
permit them to join the United Nations
until they've taken this action but
that's not enough we need to have an
active and aggressive action on part of
the president leader of this country to
seek out every possible way to get that
information which has kept the m.i.a
families in despair and doubt and mr.
Ford has just not done it Thank You
governor Carter that completes the
questioning for this evening
each candidate now has up to three
minutes for a closing statement it was
determined by the toss of a coin that
Governor Carter would take the first
question and he now goes first with his
closing remarks governor Carter
the purpose of this debate and the
outcome of the election will determine
three basic things leadership upholding
the principles of our country and proper
priorities and commitments for the
future this election will also determine
what kind of world we leave our children
will it be a nightmare world threatened
with the proliferation of atomic bombs
not just in five major countries but
dozens of smaller countries that have
been permitted to develop atomic weapons
because of a failure of our top
leadership to stop proliferation will we
have a world of hunger and hatred and
will we be living in an arms camp
stripped of our friendship and allies
hiding behind a tight defense that's
been drawn in around us because we were
fearful of the outside world will we
have a government of secrecy that
excludes the American people from
participation in making basic decisions
and therefore covers up mistakes and
makes it possible for our government our
government to depart from the principles
of our Constitution Bill of Rights or
will we have a world of peace with the
threat of atomic weapons eliminated with
full trade with our people at work
inflation control openness in government
are people proud once again Congress
citizens president Secretary of State
working in harmony and unity toward a
common future a world where people have
enough to eat and a world where we care
about those who don't can we become a
breadbasket of the world instead of the
arms merchants of the world I believe we
can and we ought to now we've been hurt
in recent years in this country
in the aftermath of Vietnam Cambodia
Chile Pakistan Angola Watergate CIA
we've been hurt our people feel that
we've lost something precious that's not
necessary I want to see our nation
return to a posture and an image and a
standard to make us proud once again I
remember the world of NATO and the world
of 0.4 and the world of the Marshall
Plan and the world of the Peace Corps
bucket we have that once again we ought
to be a beacon for nations who search
for peace and who search for freedom who
search for individual liberty who search
for basic human rights
we haven't been lately we can be once
again we'll never have that world
leadership until we are strong at home
and we can have that strength if we
return to the basic principles it ought
not to be a strength of bombast and
threats it ought to be a quiet strength
based on the integrity of our people the
vision of the Constitution and in a
strong will and purpose that God's given
us in the greatest nation on earth
business force as we have seen tonight
foreign policy and defense policy are
difficult in complex issues we can
debate methods we can debate one
decision or another but there are two
things which cannot be debated
experience and results in the last two
years I have made policy decisions
involving long-range difficulties and
policies and made day-to-day judgments
not only as president of the United
States but as the leader of the free
world
what is the result of that leadership
America is strong America is free
America is respected not a single young
American today is fighting or dying on
any foreign battlefield America is at
peace with freedom thank you and good
time
Thank You President Ford Thank You
governor Carter I also want to thank our
questioners and the audience here this
evening the third and final debate
between President Ford and governor
Carter will take place on October the
22nd at 9:30 p.m. Eastern Daylight Time
on the campus of the College of William
and Mary in Williamsburg Virginia the
subject matter will cover all issues
these debates are sponsored by the
League of Women Voters education fund to
help voters become better informed on
the issues and to generate greater voter
turnout in the November election now
from the Palace of Fine Arts Theatre in
San Francisco good night
[Applause]
[Music]